[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone and uh Welcome to our talk
on U on kedro and uh why should you use
or why should you consider start using
CRA for building um production ready
data science pipelines my name is Barbo
I'm leading the the data science uh team
at at bright Cape uh bright Cape is a we
are a data solution consultancy based in
in Inova uh and we also do a lot of work
in data engineering data analytics
process Mining and today you'll be also
besid introducing some Concepts about
cadro we'll also talk uh walk you
through a concrete use case we did on
leveraging CRA for one of our clients
where I work together with team so maybe
also well my name is Tim ragn and I'm
I'm a data scientist at bright cape and
uh well we work together on a project
for I which I will tell more about later
all right cool so quick
um um quick expectation management of
today so we're going to set the stage so
why did we choose to uh go for Cedro in
building our data science pipeline so
bit of a rational about a bit about
motivation behind actually developing
Cedro and about using Cedro in our
project a project actually project um
and then I'll be focusing mainly on the
concept on the like walk you through the
the four pillars the philosophy behind
cadro and then uh team will um dive
deeper into U the Practical use case uh
project we did for one of our clients
but before diving into uh into the
content I was i' like to ask a question
to the
audience um so what percentage you think
of advanc analytics project never make
it to production any any thoughts any
guesstimates
actually I heard 90 which is very very
close to to this based on this reference
so based uh to this article we found and
actually was referenced in multiple
places on internet it seems that around
yeah 87% 90 of advanced analytics
project never make it in production
there are many reasons for that
obviously uh maybe the business question
was not asked uh right from the from
from very start so people maybe just
wanted uh some yeah proofer concept some
extractive sign insights and never
really had this vision of um building a
project delivering a product maybe they
did have that but they didn't start uh
uh in the right way and some just data
data was just to crap for data quality
was not good enough and then it didn't
worth bringing to production but besides
the data issue and Al and besides the
asking the right questions um I think in
the end it's really about um yeah taking
a step back in the beginning and what
are you trying to build are you trying
to build like a Jupiter notebook or a
simple uh pipeline just to exract one of
insights doing one one of analysis or
are you trying to build um a product are
you trying to build something that is uh
is going to be frequently rerunning
production which is maintainable
reproducible and also um modular and in
order to get to the second state of
having this massive product which is
reliable and uh maintainable there are
many challenges that uh is we have been
facing and maybe some of you might
relate to this uh there were so many
tools out there even today by attending
the presentations like where is again a
new package polers with onx there's so
much out there so I think it's difficult
to see uh the forest through between the
trees if for the Dutch people might
relate to that a better
translation also another challenge is um
joining a project which has been uh
going on for a while and trying to
understand the code base of someone else
if there's not enough structure no
standardization and many other
challenges I'm not uh walk you through
all of them and I think maybe this one
was worth mentioning uh I've seen also
today and I think many of you don't have
a software engineering or computer
Science Background maybe just have a
science background as I have physics so
my software engineering based practi
practices or skills are far from ideal
and this is this was also one of the um
uh motivations behind kedro like how can
we embed software engineering best
practices into a tool into a framework
so that data scientist can get up to
speed uh on doing a project without
thinking of all the tiny grey software
engineering uh
details so let's uh talk about cadra
what is cadra is um open- Source python
framework is developed by Quantum black
uh very Bas in London uh and it provides
a framework for bu building reproducible
maintainable modular uh data science uh
code and data engineering data
processing code and we a couple of say
advantages of using that from our
experiences uh I mentioned already of a
software engineering best practic that
are uh embedded in it also helps uh
thanks to the design choices to create a
structure uh structure and high quality
code and very um very useful is this
Handover uh from uh development phase to
um to production phase and this is where
uh Team when is going to tell you more
about that how we did it for uh for our
client and there are four um concepts
for main characteristics of of cro it's
about it's a project template it's
inspired from the cookie cutter data
science maybe familiar with you uh so
this GES you this predefined built-in
structure of your data science project
if you don't have to think about that
anymore uh configuration this is where
you can hard code the parameters of how
to manage your data how to manage the
interface between uh data and your code
the data catalog which is uh a plain
yaml file where you can store your data
or any database connectors uh when you
move your code into production and then
everything is built into into nodes
which are nothing more than a python
function with an input and output and if
you stitch together multiple nodes you
get what's uh we get a pipeline what is
the often fancy call is a directed A
cyli R
dag um you know so in Project template
really the idea is to have this
predefined structure and you see here
uh what you get when you create from
scratch a new cro project c new and then
you you get this
um uh template this predefined folder
structure so you'll have already the
predefined places where you can store
your configuration where you could do
some uh exploratory data analysis with
notebooks where we can Define your uh uh
source code in the python script and
also you already get um or the
predefined built-in places to build your
unit testing should you go for that
another nice thing about uh kro is the
integration with the Sphinx and also
with py test uh so if you for example if
you decide to use things for documenting
your code base and if you did a nice job
in documenting your functions with Doc
strings and not provide the right um
structure then when you uh build you a
documentation the C takes care of
stitching that everything into one place
and then creating a nice HTML based
documentation probably
familiar uh for you now what about the
configuration again this is um the place
where to store the requirements for the
logging for integration for example uh
suppose that you build a data science
pipeline for would be uh uh machine
learning or predictive modeling part to
that this is where you can store the
hyperparameters of your um of your
machine learning model so you don't have
to put that uh in code uh you put them
in a separate um configuration yl files
so in order to have separation between
the the data layer the configuration
layer and and the code layer and there
also uh another advantage of
configuration is that uh you can um keep
your credentials for accessing for
example cloud storage again outside of
your code base so when when you package
and you deploy and you share your CLE
based project your credentials are
automatically not included so you don't
have to think of that they're just left
out of a packaging
step um then what about data set support
uh where is a bunch of data buil-in uh
data uh support so like the major python
package packages and with data sets are
supported think of CSV Excel data sets
paret files feather uh spark uh are
supported um and also very is support
for having your data on uh in the cloud
personally I've been using the Azure
Cloud um yeah it's there still um there
is also the nice thing about uh this
growing Community around kedro is that
uh if you don't have a connector of your
data set for example we did a project
with using kme data um then we didn't
find a predefined connector in from KRA
when we built our own custom data set
and then we want to we're going to
publish that to um to their
repository so we talked about the
project template we talked about the
configuration uh we talked about the
catalog what El um we have a nodes and
pipelines so here again node is nothing
more than uh taking a python function
and U wrapping that with an input data
set and output data set when you have
have uh multiple noes uh stitch together
uh you get the pipeline we get this
directed uh ially graph and yeah you can
imagine if you have a a large project
and you want to build it end to end from
data ingestion do have do some data
cleaning data pre-processing feature
engineering modeling and maybe also some
inference things can get pretty haic
pretty uh uh out of hand so it's good to
have uh to keep an overview hey is the
data flowing the right way from from
start to end so the developer of kro
thought of that and they developed kro
this so what you see here is a visual
representation of the P plan we have
built uh in one of our projects so here
um on the top we have input data set
this uh nice uh small um um what are
they squares there the pipelines uh and
then you see here how the data is
stitched together into the data
engineering pipeline these are the
output then they Stitch then brought
together into the data pre processing I
think and then you have here the
modeling uh some exploratory and finally
the reporting
pipeline um and this is an interactive
um web based uh tool vro V so for
example you can expand the pipeline and
you see this um like being blown up and
you see all the individual nodes that
made up the pipeline um I can also for
example if you want to select the
modeling pipeline when this is going to
be
um uh blown up and then uh zoomed on so
we can just do some uh analysis and if
you have way too much you can deselect
the data sets and then you can focus on
the on the functions on the Node and you
can also switch to White mode if you
prefer that
one um there's much more to this than uh
what we show on this uh video can also
like see a code behind it uh I think
what it misses and uh
we are in touch with a developer is
really being able to execute it from
this interface so this is purely to um
as a communication tool it's also useful
um from our experience to take the
client along especially the first weeks
when you building with data engineering
pipeline there's not so much Insight
probably coming from your work and then
the client is asking hey what am I
spending my money on and then uh is good
to show them the progress by just hey we
started with these two free nodes and
now one week later we have have a
pipeline and then in the end you start
creating some nice uh insights from your
data any questions so far before I hand
it over to uh to team yes uh thank you
very much um regarding uh the additional
data that you get after the model is
trained can this also be added in your
pipeline yeah indeed so this is train
the model from the you just need to
repeat the question yeah so the question
is um maybe if I go back here
can I go back yeah so the question is
okay we have we start with our row data
set and then we do some processes and
you get some yeah new intermediate data
set it's also uh definitely possible to
store that also in the data catalog and
this is actually what we see here these
are the raow input data set and we some
intermediate process data set and I
think some of these data sets are the
actual uh trained machine learning
models that you can eventually deploy
for example to Asia or or Amazon so you
don't have to retrain the model you just
uh get the additional data and you train
that on the new data or you have to
repeat all this process from if you get
a new data if you get new data and you
want to retrain you have to reamp a
pipeline EV but the model will be stored
somewhere in a dedicated folder so your
inference pipeline can just pick the mod
the pickle file that contains the model
and use it for
inference if no more questions
then
clicker that will be on the r well uh
thank you yonuts then I will tell a bit
more about uh our use case at FAA so who
is FAA fa is a large Dutch agriculture
player uh in the southeast of the
Netherlands and they produce uh
tomatoes to provide light to their
Tomatoes they can pick between two
options they can either directly consume
it from uh the Grid or they can produce
their own and they produce their own by
gas powered uh co-generation units why
use gas powered Co generation units uh
well due to their high efficiency so uh
it produces electricity heat and CO2 and
normally uh heat and CO2 are waste
products but of course in a greenhous
you can actually use those the second
reason is is that gas until recently was
relatively inexpensive
however we all faced it the gas prices
kind of exploded um and that made the uh
well no-brainer option uh to pick the
Cod code generation units uh was now
becoming quite
expensive um so FAA thought by itself uh
can we reduce our cost by making more
effective use of our resources and
that's where yunit and I came into play
uh so they asked us to uh write an
optimization uh model for them
uh together we decided that uh we would
split it in two phases so first a
development stage and then a production
phase uh the development stage was a
proof of concept so uh we were actually
going to show whether uh there was
a u big enough benefit for them uh by
using the optimized uh schedule uh so is
it actually worthwhile to do the project
uh and if that's the case then uh
integrated into our production systems
um well we were first running our
development development stage on our
local laptop and we were using just a
snapshot of data so an Excel data
dump after that we would integrate it
into their systems and we would run it
on a virtual machine and we would hook
it up to a SQL database which contained
live
data so what after development how did
our pipeline look like uh well cro is a
modular package and we split our uh our
pipeline into three uh modules so to
pre- optimize to ingest our data uh and
Wrangle the data and make it ready ready
for the optimization unit um there we
calculate the optimize schedule and then
uh after that we calculate all of the uh
yeah the potential cost reduction in our
post optimize and then we output
everything to an Excel so we can
visualize it to uh
foron what already strikes is that uh
optimiz is a relatively small component
of this whole model and I want to stress
that this is not necessarily where we
are using cro for we are using cro to
have the whole orchestration of this
pipeline so for the pre- optimize when
does what function run what what is
inputed to those functions um where are
my my data sets stored what uh
parameters am I
using um
uh yes and then coming back to your
question these modules can each uh run
independently of each other so you have
intermediate intermediate data sets and
with those intermediate data sets you
can run a certain module which is really
Hy during developing because otherwise
indeed you have to run everything
again so we already said we were first
using a data dump and now we are going
to use a SQL database so just short back
develop development stage was actually
successful so now uh we are going to the
production
state so switching to the SQL database
what actually changes well the pipeline
itself if the uh format of the data
Remains the Same then nothing changes
for the pipeline itself so where we need
to make our changes is actually in our
settings or configuration or more
specifically in our data catalog uh on
the right you can see for the
development stage we had a Excel data
set and for the production we are using
a SQL uh data set and of course what
comes with the SQL database is that you
also have to specify with what which uh
credentials you are uh connecting to
that data set uh to that SQL database
which you can see over
here oh we go
back um then we had our option to for
deployment well K comes with several
deployment options
um we actually could run it on a single
machine so we picked the single machine
deployment however kro does come with a
lot of uh distributed deployment um uh
guidelines and you can see that there
are many uh platforms uh which you can
integrate to
getro so for us the single machine
deployment we had three options uh uh
copy our source code create a python
package or create a tocker image uh well
the source code or uh completely copy
your source code is a complete version
uh it's really easy to share however it
has a really limited code security so
the client could accidentally make
changes to the code which we don't want
uh so we didn't want to pick that option
then the python package it's really easy
to create with cro it's easy to install
and it's also really easy to configure
another option was the docker image it
has the best security of them
all um and it has no software
dependencies however it can be a bit
more difficult to set up and especially
if AA didn't have any knowledge of uh
Docker images being run uh so therefore
and also they also already had a python
server running uh so we picked the
second
option um and what did that actually
look like what did we do uh we shared
our code through a giup repository uh
where we had our python package which we
created and that python package
contained all of the source code uh of
our
pipeline if in the future we would want
to create a new version or do an update
they would simply only have to uh
install that new file and they cannot
really change anything to the code so a
better code
security we also provided the for the
first time with a configuration so how
do how do we uh uh run the pipeline for
the first time with what with which
parameters and after that they can
change it themselves and we provided
them with documentation about the model
itself and how to install
everything um on the right you can
actually see uh what it looked like so
we had a virtu machine running with our
G package installed which contained our
pipeline uh and on that virtual machine
you have your own
config configuration as
well and in that configuration uh It
also says uh where to get your data from
from so in this case the SQL database
and also how to connect to that data
however of course what we already
mentioned those credentials you don't
want to share on a GitHub repository so
the first time you're setting it up you
have to set that up
yourself and also things that we don't
want to share is box so that's specific
to each machine that's running the code
and then afterwards fa decided that they
wanted to create a dashboard uh on the
output we delivered to the SQL database
so they were creating a
um uh they visualized what their current
decisions were so their schedule and
also what our optimized module uh set
they should be doing and then calculate
what uh the potential benefit could be
we actually already did that but they
visualized
it so what did we finally deliver we
successfully delivered a cro uh uh
project uh and we integrated it into uh
their production systems with the use of
their own dashboard they could also look
into to their past decisions and see
what they could do better in the future
so actually make those cost reductions
and uh the estimated cost prod cost redu
cost reduction was projected at 10 to
15% and well cro provided us with a lot
of tools and a lot of structure and that
we had an overview of the pipeline that
we could visualize it but I also want to
stress that the next person that is
going to use with it also has those uh
that structure so if a colleague of mine
would start a third phase he could
quickly get up to speed we have the
documentation he has a template where
he's familiar with and that's really
valuable
um and I think that's uh it any
[Applause]
questions um you cro gives a lot lot of
structure for you as a team um about the
pipeline do you see do you think that
also the client for I in this case sees
the value of that um or they see the
output and they don't you don't give
them insights in the pipeline basically
so do they see
the the added value or is it more for
the team
itself
uh oh uh so
um does the client also see the added
value of using cro and that's not only
for us giving the structure yeah I think
it's really handy for us at giving the
structure also if they would uh go to
another consultancy Pro
uh company then they could also get on
boarded with our code without us
actually telling what is happening they
could quickly install it all of the
requirements are there uh and also what
is really handy is that you can
visualize with the c visualization so
you can say we are uh calculating these
data sets for these and these reasons so
that's a bit of added value I think I
think I can add to I think it depends
very much on the client uh like if ver
was quite if you think of analytics
maturity curve a data maturity curve
they were very low they were like in the
left bottom U Corner um on the other
hand now we have been working with
another client who was a bit further
away and we uh before we delivered the
project to them we involved a python
developer so we took him along again
just the walk for the code and he
appreciated a lot the the structure and
the yeah the organization of a of a
project project very if you speak mainly
to the business probably they will
appreciate the added benefits of kro
much less than a data scientist or a
data engineer at a client who's going to
uh work with the code and hopefully
continue to improve
Itor dat science I mean like to really
stitch together everything um I think
just a little bit cookie cutter data
science uh and as I said before the
project temp is based upon that but it
it missed all the a integration and uh
that K now provides so I think besides
cookie cutter data says I didn't use
anything
else yeah
please or
experiment the
same yeah so the question is again why
did we choose uh Cedro for orchestrating
and building our uh yeah building
managing our pro pro uh projects and
it's not only about creating the
pipeline how to um how to manage and
structure our project is this question
why did we choose
cra
I think we need some other options out
there I have been using um uh C CRA
before joining Bri cap actually I was
working at Quantom black so this is
where I started to use it because we
developed kedro so I started using that
and I think we I think one or two years
ago uh cro is now part of Linux
foundation so it's now open source so
everyone can use it uh and and I think
they did do a comp competitive landscape
and there are inde some um other similar
packages and each and has pros and
conses and I think overall C at this
moment at least still provides most
benefit uh compared to the a Frameworks
so personally I just used I was very
familiar with C I did see the benefit uh
and then we yeah we using that at this
moment what was the time frame that you
took for you to build this whole
Pipeline and also question like if you
the first option so instead of do like
the manual configuration that if you
went first option how would that look in
in a manner of D and
post first option of what you said like
you had the option to go together like
um integrate with the AWS etc etc but
you went the second the botom
he talks about that uh
deployment and I I I didn't really fully
explore the distribut deployment because
we had a relatively simple uh model that
could run on a single machine yeah and I
think
we uh we are constrained by the it
environment of the client so the the the
client I think there two at least two
reason one on the other hand the client
had this python server and so already
had this predefined it infrastructure
that they gave to us hey yeah put your
code uh put your model out there uh this
is one thing and I think from a
performance perspective the pipeline is
not that heavy on resources I think end
to end I think less than half an hour to
run it and uh of course you can dep
adjust of course it's a linear
optimization model we built and you can
and have to run for 30 minutes or for 3
days and I think we I think in the end
we went for something that runs around
the 30 minutes so this is why we uh we
chose for this Does this answer your
question why we chose for this
route how long was that I think the
first phase was like three months months
or three and a half months and I think
the that's really good for us the the
moving to production was like really
much Mor shorter and I think with three
months we didn't work fulltime on the
project
maybe I know
60% yeah yeah like yeah 0.6
f one more
question maybe you sir Maybe one thing
that popped up into my head that uh I
didn't really catch here is how does it
help you version ml
models
expent that kind of workflow look like
because for us for example doing
experiments in what of these Min
solution is really quite difficult if
you stick to something like air flow
there it's because you
know
you delete the
hisory so kro has a plugin Al so the
question is again how do you uh how does
it integrate or how how do you manage uh
machine learning model how do you do
versioning on machine learning models
and is integration of ml flow and yeah
there is a plugin for uh ml flow and I
think the the pipe the video that I
showed in the beginning that bigger
pipeline um that one we had integration
to ml flow uh we did a cont regression
and then we were able with ML flow to uh
uh to monitor the versioning and that's
possible because one of the data set
that is supported by CER is an mlflow uh
artifact data set so the one hand also
storage on this but also pushes
automatically to the ml flow framework
so it pushes to it
and yes yeah so it's fully integrated
with VL
[Music]
flow